Pakistan's Supreme Court has just ruled
that prime minister Imran Khan violated
the Constitution his allies in
Parliament prevented the opposition from
proceeding with a no-confidence motion
despite the opposition having a majority
Khan then got Parliament dissolved and
called an election Osama bin Javed is
coming up for us right away from
Islamabad so Osama now that that ruling
has come through first tell us how the
Supreme Court reached this decision
well as we speak to you right now the
five-member bench is reading out its
verdict right now after hours and hours
of deliberations it was delayed by half
an hour at least before they were
supposed to announce it but we can tell
you now that the Supreme Court of
Pakistan has declared that it was
unconstitutional for the deputy speaker
of parliament to rule against the vote
of no confidence which means that the
assemblies have been restored the ruling
that the deputy speaker gave throwing
out the vote of no confidence is
enshrined in the Constitution that after
a motion has been tabled before the
assembly that the Prime Minister should
go for a vote of no confidence no other
business can take place and this was The
Plea that was brought forward by the
opposition parties to the Supreme Court
of Pakistan saying the ruling was
unconstitutional the Prime Minister saw
that he's going to lose his numbers as
the motion had been table before
Parliament he could not go back and
dissolve the assemblies and call for
elections so he used the deputy speaker
and his law minister to go through
another route which was unconstitutional
and that is what appears to be the
unanimous decision by this five-member
bench now this is going to have a
wide-ranging ramifications because soon
after that ruling the Prime Minister
wrote to the president the assemblies
were dissolved the PRI the president
actually asked for an interim government
as well and called for elections in 90
days and it appears that in after this
ruling has been declared
unconstitutional all of those subsequent
steps will be rolled back as well
so what is it that happens next what
should we be watching out for
well we've been speaking to leaders of
the opposition people who went to the
Supreme Court and some of the lawyers
who've been pleading their case as well
and they say that the first step is to
get the court to agree that no one
should be able to cite a foreign
conspiracy and strike down uh this vote
of no confidence if the supreme court
allows this then never ever in the
history of Pakistan a prime minister
would be able to vote it out of office
and the next steps would be that now uh
if the court allows them the assembly is
going to reconvene there is going to be
a vote of no confidence the opposition
says that it has more than 172 members
close to a 200 members it says it has
now who say that they do not believe
that Imran Khan should be the prime
minister of Pakistan there is also talk
about elections and that is something
that we saw in the last few days at the
Supreme Court as well uh these questions
arising on how are they going to govern
the country uh when are the elections
going to take place and what will be the
way forward word because you have to
realize that this country now is
polarized between supporters of Imran
Khan and the opponents of Imran Khan and
what this has brought to the fore as
well is the role of Pakistan's powerful
military establishment as well where
Imran Khan the sitting prime minister
for the first time has said that he was
given options by the military
establishment to either resign to
dissolve the assemblies or face the vote
of no confidence and he's found a Fourth
Way Forward and that seems to have been
struck down by the Supreme Court of
Pakistan so it is going to be a an end
to a constitutional crisis but again a
lot of ambiguity on the road ahead
because Pakistan is scheduled to have
elections a year and a half later but if
things are to go by where the opposition
has been calling for elections there has
been calls for a new mandate from the
government as well it appears that
Pakistan is probably going to be heading
towards a new Mandate of fresh elections
where people are going to decide who
they believe should be in power thank
you so much Osama bin Javed reporting
from Islamabad
foreign